[Music]
projecting military might across the
Pacific a superpower show of strength
and for the British prime minister his
most important Moment On The World stage
so far
Australian United Kingdom are of two
America's most
are common values are shared Vision more
peaceful and prosperous future unite us
all across the Atlantic and Pacific
for more than a century we stood
together to defend freedom and
strengthen democracy today about a
partnership of three English-speaking
Nations British and American nuclear
powered attack submarines sold to
Australia
the first time ever it will mean three
fleets of submarines working together
across both the Atlantic and Pacific
keeping our oceans free open and
prosperous for decades to come
the three leaders went out of their way
to claim this is not just about China
but there are no other existential
threats in the Pacific but this was all
going to put London on a faster
Collision Course with Beijing the
question is is it the right priority for
now
coming on a day this man is also
updating Britain's foreign and security
policy how does it make sense to invest
in submarines when there are some that
say that the Army is broken and we are
at war in Europe five billion pounds
more funding announced today to support
our fantastic Armed Forces with an
ambition to go even higher over time why
are we doing that we're doing it because
the world has become more volatile the
threats to our security have increased
and it's right that we as a government
me as prime minister invest
appropriately to keep us safe for 60
years Britain and America have
cooperated on nuclear-powered submarines
Australia now being brought into the
fold Mr President
this is a significant Moment In global
relations Sam coach Sky News San Diego
thanks buddy